so what I've been discovering over the
program of my research is that women and
men smoke for different reasons that for
women their smoking behaviors is much
more strongly tied to negative effect
and stress so women are more likely to
believe that smoking is going to
alleviate their stress and it's those
beliefs that are really very strongly
tied to their smoking behavior whereas
for men we see something very different
we see that their smoking behavior is
more strongly tied to the reinforcement
that they obtained from the nicotine and
cigarettes and it's this difference
that's really starting to inform how
we're going to translate this knowledge
into developing more effective
treatments which really do need to be
sensitive to these gender differences
I received pilot funding for Women's
Health Research at Yale to conduct an
experiment to look at the relationship
between mood and smoking behavior so we
brought individuals into the laboratory
we induced either a positive or a
negative mood state and then observed
how mood influenced their subsequent
smoking behavior and what we found from
that first study was that women as we
expected it's always nice when they work
out is that women when we induced a
negative mood were more likely to smoke
more quickly and they also smoked more
intensely so that means they inhaled
more deeply off their cigarettes they
took more puffs off their cigarettes
they had shorter intervals of time in
between their puffs so they just smoked
the cigarettes more intensely and also
smoked more cigarettes overall so from
this initial study we've now been able
to secure two additional grants from the
National Institutes on health to develop
a laboratory model to look at how
negative mood and stress influences
relapse what we find within this
laboratory model is that stress of
course decreases their ability to resist
smoking and it increases the amount of
subsequent smoking
much of the research focuses on the
benefits of quitting so of course you're
going to improve your health you're
going to save money etc but women
acknowledge and experience significant
risks associated with quitting so they
say if I quit smoking I'm going to be
less able to manage my stress I'm going
to gain weights I'm going to lose a
significant source of enjoyment out of
my life so we've shown that these risks
are so associated with lower motivation
to quit smoking and are also associated
so if women do try to quit these risks
are also associated with less success in
quitting smoking so we've been targeting
these wrists in terms of treatment
development and trying to develop more
effective treatments for women
so now that we've developed this
laboratory model we're now using it to
screen medications that are designed to
target the effect of stress on smoking
behavior so this is a relatively novel
strategy for smoking cessation
medications because up to this point
medications have been designed to target
either nicotine reinforcements or
withdrawal symptoms and not target the
effect of stress on smoking behavior and
we know from our prior work that stress
is a primary reason why smokers continue
smoking and this is particularly true
for women and then why they relapse back
to smoking we have been researching how
various medications target the effect of
stress on smoking behavior and I would
say that these are our most important
findings to date
we've identified a class of medications
that does reduce the effect of stress on
smoking behavior so so we're quite
excited about about this line of
research and it's a potential in terms
of being able to address this very
negative effect that stress has on
smoking behavior and we anticipate that
that as a treatment strategy this is
going to be primarily effective for
women
you